President Trump the most unconventional
presidents will speak from a very
familiar setting tonight to rally public
support he'll make a prime-time
televised speech from The Oval Office he
will try to convince voters that there
is an urgent national crisis along the
southern border and building a wall is
the way to solve it the standoff between
the president and Democratic leaders
over that wall has shut down parts of
the government for 18 days Democrats are
demanding equal airtime to respond to
the President's speech CBS News will
carry their response Paula Reid is at
the White House with what the president
is expected to say Paula good morning
good morning in his address President
Trump will argue that the situation
along the southern border is a
humanitarian and security crisis that
requires immediate action he is
demanding 5.7 billion dollars to build
his border wall but Democrats have
already said they will not provide any
funding for a wall and there appears to
be no compromise in sight so the
president is considering whether to
declare a national emergency which could
allow him to use military funds to
construct the wall but Democrats have
vowed to fight any attempts to bypass
Congress with legal challenges they also
alleged that if the president's past
statements are any indication his
address tonight will be full of quote
misinformation and malice and all of
this is happening as 800,000 federal
workers face the possibility of missing
their first paycheck this week but the
president will continue his public push
for a wall when he visits the southern
border on Thursday Gail thank you very
much